hi I'm Amelia club I'm you want to sort
them all this is where Tierra I'm going
to be completing a wired autocomplete
interview so we just said we don't have
autocue in case that's already click
auto correct yeah
[Music]
okay first question what language can
emilia clarke speak really rubbish
italian really rubbish french really
rubbish german and really really great
valerian and Dothraki shake Michela
kyani what doesn't mean a clog eat yeah
like food like alcohol I don't eat meat
but I do eat fish I did do a movie and I
was drinking a green smoothie and I
overheard someone go I heard all she
eats is grass I eat more than grass
folks you had a hair fast doesn't mean
the have tattoos I do I have one
here and I have another one hiding here
that's white this is a B for me before
you I got it on that movie because it
just had such a wonderful time I'm gonna
get a dragon everyone so I think that's
weird is the dress the dragon I want to
go here right and I'm not gonna let you
know where I'm right but you doesn't
mean it clock was a fan mail oh my god
yeah I do actually that's terrible
should know that they should know that
cuz I respond I really do if you're nice
if you're not nice then no no why did
Woody Harrelson wear pajamas I assume
they met that time at last time I was in
can maybe they're very comfortable I'm
not done with my pajama wearing Woody
Harrelson sing cheers theme song the
show was on before I came on to it and
that song was already there why does
woody look like that
oh that mean yeah that's that's pretty
funny I saw that that is kind of odd in
it yeah I really do does Woody Harrelson
sing take a long ride on my motorbike
you know I'm ready
there's Woody Harrelson have tattoos I
have no courage for tattoos they scare
me
it's Chewbacca you a wookie yes a girl I
think we would classify Chewbacca as a
man that's traditional yes exactly
what Betsy were born with is Chewbacca a
dog I mean actually Chewbacca was based
on a dog that George Lucas had riding on
his passenger seat in his car she was
based on a dog yeah
Indiana was the dog's name Wow and when
I met George Lucas he immediately tried
to put a collar on me and I escaped
lovely ma'am
I met him at the premiere it's Joe Baca
going to die oh wow so dog if anyone is
bold enough to try
they'll be met with Ferrari resistance
oh and it's gonna be mad for the other
guy Chewbacca is yeah exactly
what is Chewbacca's language it is sheer
Ewok and the language something like
this he just asked you all out on a date
no everyone else else okay my fiance
wouldn't like that
does does Chewbacca get a medal he sheds
he should he should get him a tank you
definitely should absolutely get a medal
let's try to make that happen
let's let's write someone I think we
should George if you're watching mm-hmm
where is Woody Harrelson from born in
Midland Texas grew up in Houston but now
I'm from Hawaii is Woody Harrelson and
Oscar winner oh thanks for asking that
question that was a rough one
no so is Woody Harrelson a good baller
no Harrelson related to Matthew
McConaughey
he's my brother full brother wasn't
actually good at basketball
excellent I'm not afraid to mix it up in
the paint you know what I mean Oh got
this cool you get to hold this one
progress is emilia clarke human one oh
no no that's like salt in the wound okay
okay pretend let's hope people let's
hope all vote anyway right dude thank
you
look at that dude immediate Clark eater
wheel uh-oh
I wish I could say yes but it's a no it
was some kind of gelatin it tasted real
good and I got real happy because eating
a real raw horse heart for 18-hour
filming day would have made me quite ill
I also don't have the teeth for it quite
chewy okay is a miracle arc British no
I'm actually America and I've just been
flying the entire time I just thought
it'd be so much funnier if I would just
pretend to be British because I think
everyone's like smarter when the British
say what age is a media clock never tell
someone what your real age is 31 said it
already there you go
ripe old age of 31 I'm 31 but you're 31
86 he's only an 86 tober the third 25
next time joined birthday he'll be
basketball what's in Han Solo's pocket I
don't know what was Han Solo frozen in
carbonite
what is Han Solo's job scoundrel
criminal what did Han Solo Oh Jabba very
good question
those Han Solo have the force obviously
who is your honest or that's a great
question can you tell a man from Finland
I play Chewbacca in Seoul or Star Wars
stories babe guys two years
thanks Hey all in your honor swadharma
acident Chewbacca Solo a Star Wars story
a local bus that was saying this in
Finnish
how tall is Yanis on news yeah I'll call
me that was second as rest of them are
actually just very I am two meters 11
and a half centimeters and I I round
that up to 7 feet Wow 5 - how big is the
to eat at who's gonna be at least at
least 5 maybe don't overdo it
[Laughter]
it's my college age well done
[Music]
did you have a good time I had a great
time I played beer pong became the
champion of tequila basket
how many for you were seven foot you do
the same did you miss your basketball
one but I did a basketball I have when I
Blasket ball play played for 20-25 years
they call me to be Chewbacca and at that
point I said maybe it's time to quit a
basketball and go a Chewbacca odd say
your shoe size is something on the lines
of 2922 guest UK size 15 US size 16 I'm
full I'm in UK size 4 remember that time
you took a nap in my shoes when I was
then I accidentally put them on in your
luggage is Malayan thousand faster than
the enterprise definitely is the
Millennium for sale how much you got
why is the money in thousand considered
junk I don't consider it John does the
Millennium Falcon have a bathroom course
what do you think people just walking
around constipated all the time in the
Millennium Falcon
where is the Malayan powder now my best
guess Pinewood Studios London
this is Emilia Clarke saying goodbye to
you in wookie what he said